One way of shaping traffic is with what's called a Leaky Bucket Traffic
Shaper. Where each flow has its own bucket. In a Leaky Bucket
Traffic Shaper, data arrives in a bucket of size
beta. And drains from the bucket, at rate rho. The parameter rho
controls the average rate. Data can arrive faster or slower
into the bucket. But it can not drain at a rate faster than rho. Therefore, the
maximum average rate that traffic can be sent
is this smooth rate, rho. The size of the
bucket controls the maximum burst size that a
sender can send for a particular flow. So
even though the average rate cannot exceed rho,
at times, the sender might be able to send
at a faster rate, as long as the total size of the burst does not exceed
the size of the bucket. Or does not
overflow the bucket. The leaky bucket allows flows
to periodically burst, and the regulator at the
bottom of the leaky bucket ensures that the
average rate does not exceed the drain rate
of the bucket. For example, for an audio application,
one might consider setting the size of the
bucket to be 16 kilobytes. So, packets of
one kilobyte would then be able to accumulate a burst of up to 16 packets in
the bucket. The regulator's rate of eight packets per second, however,
would ensure that the audio rate would be smooth to an average
rate not to exceed 8 kilobytes per second or 64KBps.
Setting a larger bucket size can accommodate a larger burst rate. Setting
a larger value of rho can accommodate or enable a
faster packet rate. The leaky bucket traffic shaper was developed in 1986
and soon to follow was a technique called RT traffic shaping.